foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
Fight Night flashbacks cause today Eric
we are gonna take you down the Kamara
Usman road and it is a fun road all
right I've heard the name but I'm not
quite familiar that's the whole thing
about me doing this is I'm learning with
you people too that are watching that
don't know much about this either so I'm
going to be asking the questions that
you would probably want to ask too so so
he's the uh the number one literally the
number the number one pound for pound
number one fighter in the world any
weight class he's number one pound for
pound weight class is he in he's at
welterweight 170 which there's some
Talent at 170. and he is he's undefeated
in the UFC he's never lost he's about to
break if he wins this weekend against uh
Leon Edwards he's about to break
Anderson Silva's record for most title
defenses he's a Savage and then and then
undefeated sounds crazy to me because
especially at 170. yeah I just don't I
know that there's not a lot of people
that can can survive this without
blemishes on their record exactly it's
not like boxing where guys you know 50-0
or whatever like in UFC you know there's
too many ways to lose guys are too good
especially what's fun about Kamara
usman's come up is he he's a wrestler by
trait that's his background wrestler
damn good wrestler too he doesn't have
the fancy Penn State or uh Oklahoma uh
state or Ohio State pedigree he arrests
a division two School uh Nebraska
Kearney I think he's a national champion
there All-American there uh Savage
straight up just a wrestler okay I was
gonna ask a question no jiu jitsu that's
what I was going to ask is that a common
path uh College uh wrestling is that a
common path to go into the UFC yeah I'd
say common because those guys have a set
of skill and like mindset that
translates well to the to be a UFC
fighter okay so he comes from now it's
still a common path but now you really
can't get in the UFC just as a good
wrestler and have success now the game's
evolved where guys are too good at
everything people's take down defense or
world class so you have to have a little
more than just wrestling there's a guy
named Bo Nichols who comes from Penn
State who's a he's the biggest Prospect
in years and he's just straight
wrestling and he's he had one fight on
Dana White Contender series starch the
dude is everybody for the UFC and Dan's
like well hold on let's do a few more
and then we'll get to UFC the games
change a little now so with Kamara Usman
you'll see as we go through these fights
when we go through three of his biggest
ones I'll film the gaps in between but
he starts out as you know he's a
straight wrestler not the most exciting
guy so is this his first fight we're
gonna watch so this is his first
official UFC fight that's his Ultimate
Fighter uh 21 finale so you have to win
in the house go undefeating the house to
get to The Ultimate Fighter finale he
fights hater Hassan and uh you know he
gets the job done here but you'll notice
as we get through his fights you see as
they evolve how much he evolved Savage
gotcha
skinny legs do wrestler versus Striker
skinny little legs too okay well quick
question though
if uh not knowing anything about the
fighters and You Haul and you saw
boxer
it said fighter and the other one said
wrestler wrestle all day you would take
the wrestler because you know what the
wrestler dictates where the fight's
gonna go the boxer can't it's
interesting the boxer can only keep it
on the feet the wrestler can go well
I'll go on the floor I'll go on the
ground it's up to me now is that because
that's also because
like if you want a box I don't have to
buy correct and you have that's all
that's all you can do yeah you're gonna
take me down that's why I like Patty
yeah yeah do it all yeah yep so this is
the start of the second round okay
Ultimate Fighter finale and this is the
start to the pound for pound number one
guy in the world now but again you'll
see the evolution of Kamara usman's
career from this fight to the next one
now remember he does have a shadow
casted over him because at 170 that's a
GSP land so there's a debate and even
Dana thinks come out this one's better
than GSP as far as goat status so
there's a debate because over the
welterweight division is George
St-Pierre he's one of the top three most
famous fighters of all time most
successful gotcha so he has to deal with
that got you hit it
got you yeah you know him from Captain
America what was he in the second one
the Winter Soldier was it [ __ ] uh
George Saint Pierre yeah but who is he
in the movie oh
go here we go
oh yes so you'll see he gets wobbled
there but see so wrestling's his
pedigree this guy's throwing bombs by
the way yeah but suppose oh wow so he's
explosive oh he's strong as hell very
strong yeah very strong and what's crazy
about him what I think makes him an
outlier is Kamara usman's mentality like
he's fought where like now you know he's
35 I think now oh so it's coming to an
end well correct so he don't have a ton
of fights left but he also has like
there's been fights where his knees are
his bad knees his knees are so bad he
can't run or Spar he'll still take the
fight and just do like a aerodyne bike
or something like that or Swim a lot no
sparring no grappling and then beats the
very best in the world so to me Kamara
Usman which makes him an outlier even on
the the pound for pound list is his
mentality so what I'm watching here is
like he like you say he has skinny legs
but it looks like that we have no skinny
legs means it has better movement of
those legs I mean he's built like he's
built like a stingray yeah yeah
I'm actually literally the reverse
they'd call me the ostrich you know what
I mean big in the middle
so he gets a head arm choke here for his
first one ultimate fighters then who
would have thought you know that doesn't
that didn't look boring at all man no he
looked I'm just saying that's his
brother that giant guy he just won the
recent ultimate fight that giant man is
his brother yeah well that's that's
that's where he trained yeah yeah yeah
growing up growing up with yeah if that
was your brother that's where you
trained yeah when your brother's
Nigerian Juggernaut you're gonna grow up
pretty tough yeah well I I think that
like he's almost has like a weird
prototype like a a special prototype
body for this 100 and like again his
legs aren't massive but neither are Jon
Jones like there's some skinny legs I
don't know what it is but Jon Jones to
me found Grace of all time
top five of all time they have these
really skinny legs well because what I'm
saying with his skinny legs he's able to
like you know he's he he's he can turn
into a pretzel look at him but you know
what else cardio like as far as cardio
goes it would be tough to argue that
Camaro's gonna have the best cardio in
the game especially with his fighting
style like he'll shoot so many times
even if he doesn't have success he keeps
shooting that's a cardio thing that's a
mental strength and then also his cardio
second Next Level oh man I have I always
want to ask what is that feeling
what is that feeling you're in some sort
of somebody's got you in some kind of
hole somebody's got you in a hole that
your arm's about to break or whatever
like what is that moment that you just
like how does that feel just have to be
like
come on man well in the fight it's weird
because if it's like a arm like an arm
like like an arm bar or a camera or like
a shoulder lock or like an ankle lock or
even guilting you're drilling so high
that usually in training you tap early
but since you're in front of a live
crowd like hopefully I can get out of it
well sometimes it's too late and you
break the ligaments
is that what happens like I've never
been Trader I should have tapped out
early 100 well but then again you don't
tap out early because you're like ah
maybe maybe the the let go I can get out
so it's a tough for a fighter it's tough
so that is a weird moment in the ego of
a fighter well now think about this
think of like uh no Guerra big nog who I
thought didn't go my way fought them in
Brazil but he was a guy who was Mr
Jujitsu Mr submission then he fights guy
and Frank Mayer and Frank Mayer gets him
in a arm lock a camera and it I mean
he's the face of Brazil he's Mr Jutsu
he's like well I don't tap I can't tell
he had app though huh didn't tap what he
blew his shoulder out it's one of the
most it goes snap oh loud the whole
Arena goes like Oh my God and then the
ref called it no you have to have to but
there's guys where that [ __ ] happens
where they just don't okay as a former
fighter as a fan of fighting yeah
what is your gut feeling to that let me
add these are the two things is it
man that guy's tough or is it just tap
bro when it's no Guerra and like I know
like he's he can't go back home to
Brazil if he Tapped Out the you know
he's Mr Jitsu so it's better me it's
like it's better just to have like you
can't use your arm builds his legacy for
people to walk around and be like it's
like good you did bro yeah oh that's wow
yeah I mean yeah that's some Macho
[ __ ] right there but I get it I get
it so just keep going might get off this
nerd stuff for a second
and then uh right like win a soldier you
know what I'm saying hello I know one of
the greatest adventure movies
wow who are you my boy Frank grillo's in
it too can you watch Winter Soldier is
one of the best of this a whole
franchise here's my thing here's my
thing with Captain America what's a
superpower
what's it the the the shield are you
kidding me he don't fly he took some
super soldier serum he's got super
healing super strength okay super
strength yes okay so he's on steroids
yes so just yeah you're right but that's
not a super power right like you have
here's the word it's not your steroids
he's on the steroids really yeah he can
lift a car over his head he's not doing
[ __ ] Barry Bond steroids can he can
he live does he live yes he's super
strong but we have Hulk for that right
no Hulk is like super super strong okay
he's dead there's levels there's levels
I'm just saying that with all the things
if Captain America fought you in the UFC
I'd be [ __ ] you'd be [ __ ] you wouldn't
even be able to do when you saw her
wouldn't pass it he failed the drug test
but also
so there's no fight there
yeah but also if we're yeah Captain
America uh he's suspended for six months
for uh for super soldiers for two years
for having Nazi steroids yeah yeah but
anyways let's get back to you know let's
get back here your lack of I'm just
saying if I'm flying somewhere there's a
mission and it's just me and Captain
America like where's the rest though
right like where's storm at I I can't
where's Jean Gray storm where's Jean
Gray oh my God oh my God oh my God storm
is with the X-Men okay you know what
let's just go back let's go back to what
you know
hold on hold on there's a whole
different podcast right now because you
are driving me banana it could be you
educating me on Marvel DC that's what
that's especially the next one we do all
right uh hold on it's Captain America DC
Jean Gray Captain America's DC he's
Marvel Marvel so he can [ __ ] with them
right
they don't they never get together and
storm is with the X-Men they don't
necessarily work with they've never
worked together it's like the UFC versus
like Bellator yeah whatever that is in
uh Europe and they just don't work
together they don't necessarily work
together well that's a shame well that's
a shame yeah but Captain America is an
outraged I'm outraged but then Captain
America works with the Avengers correct
yes not but no X-Men No X-Men all right
say less I think it's the same I think
they should collab
uh so anyway back to Kamara Usman I'm
with all the haters now
you create a Reddit profile yeah yeah
yeah I'm on that red Captain America
Captain America Juice Head 777
learn your facts before you oh my God
can anybody real you realize Brendan
asked him why Captain America's not with
the ax man let's take a little break
from chatting with Eric Griffin about
the pound for pound number one fighter
in the world Kamal Usman because this
weekend Camaro is fighting yep that's
right his belt is on the line against
Leon Edwards it's a rematch but you want
to watch UFC 278 you do it's
action-packed Fight Card capped off by
an anticipated Kamal Uso and Edwards
match which I just told you about throw
down and grab your own epic Victory
draftking Sports Book that's right the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC this Saturday at 7 p.m we have a cal
bass fight campaign with the boys new
customers can bet just 5 five dollars
and get two hundred dollar rules and
free bets instantly win or lose that's
not enough action you can also get in
the 10 risk-free same game parlay I'd
say same fight parlay DraftKings just
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will come out on top how long will the
fight last and so much more I like the
dogs there
I like all the dogs the chance of them
all winning aren't good but you could
put just ten dollars in for all three of
them to win you can make bank so if you
take Jose Aldo who's a dog if you take
Leon Edwards who's a dog I think the
biggest dog out of all of them you take
Luke rockhold you bet ten dollars you
make a bank on a parlay there just
saying if you want to get risky with it
chance of it winning is not good but I
like my odds there download the draft
game Sportsbook app right now use promo
code shop show Schaub show bet five
dollars on UFC 278 and get two hundred
dollars in free bets instantly that's
code shop show this Saturday at
DraftKings Sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the UFC
minimum age eligibility restrictions
Supply C show notes for details
DraftKings promo code shop show anyways
Usman so who's been wins The Ultimate
Fighter finale starts his UFC career and
then he goes on a path now what's crazy
is they give him Leon Edwards who he
fights this Saturday in the main event
on pay-per-view to uh you'll see 278
Leon Edwards has gone on a [ __ ] tear
too so you have Kumar Usman his like
first legit fighting you'll see if they
give him Leon Edwards was a beast he
beats him via decision all wrestling
that's wrestling for Striker they've
both gone on to get much better but then
he goes on four more wins then he
finally gets a KO over Sergio morias
which is pretty big deal uh then he gets
three more wins by decision again
wrestling there against Damian Maya
Rafael dosanchos who used to be a former
uh world champion so now he's like 7-0
at this point yes and then they give him
Woodley for and Woodley at the time was
uh the champion and he out wrestles
Woodley he was the really the first one
to Break Woodley like you can see
Woodley in that fight looking at the
clock and [ __ ] he breaks Woodly because
his pressure tenacity is insane so then
the legend of Camaro's one starts with
his win over Woodley once he beats
Woodley it's nuts man so then after he
beats Woodley becomes Champion then he
fights I think his toughest opponent
ever and I think they should fight every
Saturday Colby Covington who is like if
Kamara usman's 1A Kobe Compton's 1B if
there's no Kamar Usman could we
Covington is your world champion guys he
has the correct Usman has but just
they're around the same time both in the
primes he just can't beat camarosman
because everything Kobe does uswin just
does a fraction better so you have good
boxing you have good cardio cool
so he knocked him out in the boxing and
one of the greatest fights of all time
then they had a rematch so he so he
beats Willie becomes Champion fights
Kobe Compton classic UFC 245. he beats
uh Colby in the fifth round late but
it's a great fight and then they give
him Jorge Mazda which is a huge star
Jorge Mazda kind of boring late fight
um you can tell like Camaro kind of
played it safe did a lot more wrestling
Helm Against the Cage not the funnest
fight so then they give him Gilbert
Burns now Gilbert Burns is you know top
three in the world at the time I think
he was ranked number two and Gilbert
Burns and him were training partners for
years they came up with the same gym for
years and all of Gilbert Burns training
partners and coaches went hey man when
these two would Spar get what burns
would beat the [ __ ] out of him you're
like what really and
we're talking about practice though
we're talking about practice
in the game time I'm not been against
Kumar Usman so even though everyone told
me who I respect told me I'm telling you
man Gilbert whoops his ass in training
went all right I bet you come on still
wins so probably that overconfidence is
what messed with
with fireworks yep but you'll see we're
gonna watch this fight now so you know
Gilbert comes out and you'll notice here
too tomorrow because Gilbert is a world
champion Jiu Jitsu practice on the
ground but they've both got better at
striking so so it's a stand-up War but
you see early on this is the start of
the fight Gilbert lands a big shot it's
it's the closest Camaro's been to being
finished he lands a bomb and Gilbert
Burns can he has heavy hands but he
lands one and you're like God Doug this
could be a long night for Kamara Usman
but then again tomorrow's mindset man
that's the thing about this dude is when
even when he's doing bad he just he
thinks he's going to find a way out of
it that one looked like it hurt got him
in this got him in this that's a side
kick for your ass right there and this
is a big ass pay-per-view but it's also
during the pandemic so you see oh see
that he's laying in that wobble them
wobble them I sure did nice going for
blood here too nobody
now watching this oh he's quick watching
the Syracuse like oh tomorrow's about to
lose this fight man this is not good so
he's right there he's wobble trying to
get his bearings back starts laying the
jab but you notice he's a different
fighter than even that first fight you
saw was all grappling look at him now
look at this move well you said movement
uncomfortable you know I'll say this
real quick
from the all the fights that I've
watched you guys with you yeah one thing
I say about this guy
like I've seen in all the other fights
when a person takes a punch like that I
could see that the fight's over
but this guy I don't see that nope
that's why he's the pound for pounds I
see him just being like he gets better
now this this that this thing right here
tickles me this is like some fifth grade
like get off me get off me it's a it's a
weird exchange now there's certain guys
on the bottom they can throw up Kicks
and they've knocked dudes out but also
Herb Dean should stand them up here but
also Kumar Usman herb should know what
he's dealing with here because come on
don't want to go in his guard he's a
world but why why is the guy on the
ground doing this instead of staying
because he wants him to come down and
then also because Camaro's so close if
he gets up he's more susceptible being
punching the kicked in the [ __ ] face
so camar just needs to back up why does
he just really hurt him take his legs
like he's about to you know yeah I feel
you really he was like really her things
just step in right I don't know why
Herb's letting this go I mean oh usually
you kick the back of the hamstrings
which sucks but it's not doing much man
yeah this is a weird fight yeah you just
grab his legs right you can probably go
the second round now yeah that was weird
because that's that's yeah
let's take another little break from
chatting with that boy Eric Griffin and
just educate him on Kamal ooze Ben all
right and cabal gots confidence in
fellas hey ladies for that matter but
fellas
you can't have any more confidence when
you're properly groomed that's right
there's a big kind of vibe to you man
you can just tell by the way these dudes
carry themselves all right we call this
BGE big groom energy all right and
there's only one way to get that BGE
that's with manscape my friends at
manscaped we want to introduce you to
the biggest best Ultimate hygiene bundle
yet the Platinum package 4.0 is here
from manscape is the listen they're the
leader in below the waist grooming now
trust with them with the rest of
everything going on with grooming join
the four million Bros worldwide who
trust manscape by going to manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with the
code Shob 20. manscape's brand new
Platinum 4.0 package is the biggest
bundle they've ever offered all right
and they're giving you a discount on
manscape's top products the manscape
Platinum package 4.0 is the One-Stop
shop for a dude who deserves it oh
what's inside this package well you get
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker ear nose hair trimmer the
ultimate premium body wash Ultra Premium
two in one shampoo conditioner Ultra
Premium deodorant crop preserver
anti-shaping ball deodorant crop reviver
ball spray toner anti-shaping boxes the
shed travel bag to hold all this stuff
where you need it get 20 off and free
shipping with the code shop20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
shop20 schaub20 unlock your big groomed
energy with manscaped and remember when
you trim the hedges the tree stands
taller fellas
but also here
um
one of the major reasons why Kamara
Usman striking has gotten better over
the years and throughout the fights and
he's able to stand with anybody now is
because he linked up with Trevor Whitman
who was my coach in Denver who I started
with my very first coach Trevor
Whitman's like a boxing extraordinaire
all he knows is boxing he's a monster at
it so uh Kamara Usman went all right I
became Champion with Woodley dominating
the wrestling I need to get better at
striking sought out Trevor Whitman in
Denver Colorado so now he does half his
camp in Denver half of his camp in
Florida just to work with Trevor just to
get his hands better and it show you'll
see because he starts knocking dudes out
because you see this when he gets a
knockout the Mazel Dawn one oh he's
knocked out oh
and you'll notice his his jab is what
you can really tell Trevor Whitman is a
great job all about the jab jab
specialist oh oh
and see
that's what I'm that look is what I'm
talking about
that that's not snowflake yeah that's
not snowflake that guy had to look like
oh no this is gonna yes this is gonna
hurt me
so this is now the third round is it
about even at this point or who's who's
in the lead at this point uh Gilbert won
the first round uh Kamar won this the
second now we're in the third and you'll
see with Kamara too he does not get
tired he can go all day
whatever Captain America is on he's
probably on
so yeah that jab all of them oh oh okay
come on
and his ground and pound is filthy see
what I'm talking about you just get get
in get on them
we see how the guy's trying to get up
and just get his ass whooped stop the
fight
that was a big one from him because
again if you're losing in training that
has to stick with you mentally but Kamar
Osman just doesn't give a hug now what I
like about him he's not jumping on the
uh the railing yeah this is just
menacing right here and he's also not
he's not flashy you know what I'm saying
well yeah but this is kind of he's
pissed because everyone thought Gilbert
was going to beat him like his teammates
and everyone was like I think Gilbert
wins this there's his giant brother
but when you're as great as he is I feel
like right like you wouldn't want to
fight this guy ever but in this moment
right here I wouldn't want to see him on
the streets
like that moment right there where he
when you take a dude that just won a
fight that was the underdog you take him
and then you put him in a fight yeah
like they put him right on the streets
right now somebody got beat up if you're
like thanks for the time all right get
out the door he's like no no no and
you're in Vegas or some [ __ ]
this he he won there on that hit boom
that's the one oh wow that's a jab folks
yeah
and now he's like way down there [ __ ]
child's pose boom oh that's it get off
of him all right all right
what is the ref trained at what moment
is when he sees it the person's helpless
yeah we can't defend himself anymore
when it's just like he's so beat up man
so he could he could let go on longer
but it's just gonna do more yeah that
one hit though was like oh I can't let
another one like that go 100 like yeah I
can't let another one like that land oh
[ __ ]
so the next one so this is a rematch so
the first one I told you so he beat
Woodley right and then they give him uh
Jorge shortly after that and it was a
short notice in Abu Dhabi it's during
the uh it's during covid so they're
they're fighting on fight Island Abu
Dhabi and so this is a rematch and they
talk so much [ __ ] to each other because
the first one
you know people are like oh my God Lost
His short notice and it was kind of a
boring fight you're like all right
whatever so this one like well miles of
all training this could be a different
answer and it's different but it doesn't
go Jorge's way you'll see this is when
the Superstar of Camaro swing he had won
the first fight he went dominant and it
was just boring held me as a cage just
grappled again she's just wrestling so
they've been both so they don't like
each other they legit don't like each
other
yep
[Laughter]
oh it's the same raft too yep yeah herb
Dean's kind of there's only one ref and
you have no for the for the main event
at Tim there'll be one Grease man and
only one round yeah
just exhausted yeah
but you'll see now like notice from that
first fight we watched
notice how much grappling these are and
now come and Jorge is a Savage dude
Savage on the feet like monster knockout
artist knocked up and asked oh so he's
knocked out during two he's now trained
with the Denver boxing guy and now he's
in here ready for it all yep that's that
he looks dangerous he's he's just
improved he's improved so much
I I like that he doesn't waste a lot of
movement I see a lot of these other guys
dancing too much you know like just a
little bit tight yeah yeah and he's kind
of like his footwork seems to have a
purpose Jorge doesn't either and Jorge
is a guy who came up with uh Kimbo Slice
in the backyards in Miami he was like 14
fighting those
Jorge is a little he disguys that'd be a
[ __ ] oh
oh wow come on now how I mean from that
from from watching that to that first
open fighter fight you're talking about
a completely different animal well I
just watch it can we see it again oh
you'll see it again you'll see look now
look Kobe's saying he wants some
I'm just is that is that in the contract
please go Shake Dana White's hand
he's just fired up no I'm just saying
but I've seen that like 17 times now but
you get to jump over the thing and you
got to go over to Dana White and be like
it's like
this Cuba Cuba Gooding Jr is ringside
too all hyped up before all those
accusations he was like show me the
money it's his only life show me the
money everyone's like bro we got it well
this I mean the guy was being a little
bit too uh careless that's Jorge though
Jorge is like okay that was careful you
don't you know you don't poke the bear
like that he was uh
bro
and what's he feeling right now that's
the first time I think Jorge's been not
cold like that too look at him he's been
fight forever bro like I told you he
started with Kimbo Slice in Dade County
Miami on YouTube in the backyard fights
yeah he's young kid I guess I guess you
can't hate a dude after a guy beats you
like that I have that respect yeah
that's what I'm saying you
I don't think dude let me add this to
question I'm asking can you be a great
fighter
and not have respect for all of these
opponents I don't think so because you
guys go through such a unique situation
like you know what it took to get in
there win or lose like you two went
through that you know
oh I missed it I missed the it's funny
that he hit him it's funny how he hit
him so hard here it is like a really
good box wow
inside the hook and then the rest of
this is kind of just like ah
well that's that's just
he starts scratching you know what the
[ __ ] yeah this this is like whoop
wow oh oh with a a show oh oh Nobody
Does this nobody nobody so he had to
watch this you can you you there was
nothing you could say about this doctor
no no that's it no martial gave him
credit too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
nothing yeah
because he said he knocked me to
look at them look at Rogan grabbing
everybody yeah
they go nuts I think in DC
[Music]
uh why does Rogan always look like he's
getting the best [ __ ] ever
so he's like this
he's like finishing like he's with his
buddies at the strip club yeah
they've only seen three thousand
knockouts I don't know if I'd want my
kid to be there at this moment if you
come out who's been you're undefeated
you do now if you're a guy who wins some
loses some bright put the kids bed early
when Daddy fights
but yeah this is the legend of Kumar
Usman man and then now he's gone on to
beat Kobe coming in again in a rematch
he's beat all comers there's really no
one for him but there's that guy Leon
Edwards who's won 10 in a row and then
now you know he's went down a row
they've both gotten better I don't see
uh the outcome be different I think
camarosman still beats him and breaks
and Silva's record but it's a tough
[ __ ] fight for Kamara Usman but he
wins this one now he's talking about
he's cleaned out the entire [ __ ] uh
welterweights in all the world so now
he's talking about maybe jump in a light
heavyweight because tell me what you
think about this so the other champion
at middleweight which we usually the
next weight class you'd go fight at
because that's kind of similar to your
weight yeah what is what's the weight
185 185 middleweight oh so one seven
he's at 175 and you have he's at 170.
170 to 185 185 is a big jump so he wants
to bypass 85 and go to light heavyweight
which is 205 which is insane but the
reason he wants to do it tell me how you
feel about this the champion at
middleweight is Izzy
Israel and Sanya who's also African so
he doesn't want to take away his title
and fight him because they're both from
Africa now they didn't grow up together
they don't train together yeah they're
just African
yeah can you imagine if a white guy I
don't know if they like the tone of how
you said African but you know I'm just
but I'm just saying can you but you put
a little extra on it a little more
flavor you put some flavor on you put
some spice on the Africa can you imagine
if an American was like I ain't fighting
any Americans man you're like well you
don't have a career it's different
because you wouldn't because it's mostly
Americans but like
um I don't know I don't know if I have
any feeling about it but I understand it
I understand I understand if there's
only like I'm just asking like if you
can count like if there's only if
there's only uh three or four Africans
fighting probably like eight okay and
there's only one of them's champ well
there's three Champs okay yeah Francis
you should fight him Yeah Izzy and him
yeah he should fight him he should fight
him it'd be different if it was like
there's only four Africans including him
and the other guy you're talking about
you're a champion he's a champ and you
want to make sure that you know there's
at least two African Champs at all times
yeah then I'm like okay I get it okay to
just to to represent back home but if
it's like eight and there's three
Champions it's like go get the belt but
okay but you said something that I find
strange strange so he's at 170. so that
is means that he has to cut weight to
170. the day before the show he has to
make 170 pounds right fight what sizes
he had to fight one a plus one 186 187
he probably did 180 . yeah but then
Izzy's probably 200 okay I guess you're
saying you know so 85 are big boys like
Luke rockhold walks at 220. so if you
walk around normally 170 ish oh if
you're once if you're 170 without like
cutting weight yeah you're fighting at
55. some of them will fight at 45. ah
like these boys kind of if you had the
kind of it's an art that's what I was
going to say it's a beast it's just like
it's a fight in itself so if you have
like the metabolism to like
but that's why it's a young man's game
it's a discipline yeah it's a discipline
thing
I was like that's what we got to get
like added have you seen Patty recently
is he fat yeah which I love I can't get
enough of it he's so fat yeah but he's
what he's still he's 20 what
27.97 yeah just doing the guy he got two
more years where he's not gonna be able
to I give him another year bro before
we're like hey man his coach like gay
bro
he's over 200 pounds wow which I can't
get I love it it's so entertaining what
does he fight again this is part of his
thing yeah
you don't get out of shape come out
Usman number one guy in the world
he's 35. wow this so we're coming to the
end here yeah that's why after Leon
Edwards there's nothing for him they're
delicious money money the and Legacy
like hamzat at 70 maybe if he went on a
streak and did his thing they could do
it but
so let's say he loses to Edwards oh then
then there's a rematch rematch and then
you might get one more album but I only
think I think Camaro has maybe two
flights left so so to you
this is the biggest fight of his career
just for legacy's sake for sure you know
I mean every fight but the fight before
this if you would if he lost a Mazda if
he lost to Gilbert Burns if he lost a
Mazda the first time he'll last but this
is more and more at stake here because
he he did he wins this fight he breaks
the record correct big deal and it's to
be honest you look at his last couple
fights like it's his toughest fight I
think since Kobe Covington even though
his last fight was against Kobe
Covington he's beat Kobe twice now so
you know but it's a tough fight but this
is
Claire's day a better Striker but is
this also the first time someone has
gone undefeated to this point
no when he fought uh Colby I think
Kobe's on feet he fought Woodley who was
a champion at the time so he's fought
some mods I know but who has who has
gone undefeated so he's not Leon Edward
says right like Leona versus last thing
you see before but he's on a 10-fight
win streak which at 170 is unheard of
okay guy oh this is a huge fight there
huge fight big fight wow tough fight for
him
Saturday Saturday you'll see 278 might
have to watch that one get you some I
love how we sell you on these and you
tune into them yeah because it's like
this is interesting UFC I'll bill you
later
I appreciate you brother hope your
camarosman fan now we know you're a
Paddy fan yeah thank you guys for tuning
in until next time